blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an
entire non-fiction book in just 15
minutes you can try it for free
and get 25 off a subscription by going
to blinkist.com
pakman all right i want to start today
with what's happening
in the israeli-palestinian conflict
where once again we have another
major flare-up and no clarity at this
time whether this will be
on the order of weeks or months in
duration or possibly
even longer now normally i would just
jump
right into the story and what's going on
and my perspective
but because of what i came into my
office to
this morning dozens and dozens of
emails and messages from people
speculating as to why i haven't talked
about this yet
making all sorts of of accusations and
allegations some of them very just sort
of sad in terms of what they
imply people think is my life on sort of
a day-to-day basis and
i've not spoken about this recent
flare-up
much yet only three times on the
recent bonus show and a couple times on
recent live streams
i've not spoken much about it yet
because i've not felt that i have much
to add or say that's different
from my analysis the last time we talked
about it but i received a couple of
emails
from long time viewers respectfully
saying this feels like it could be
different this time and it would be
great for you to update your take on
what's going on
and so i'm going to do it i also receive
dozens of
furious and often emails playing on
anti-semitic tropes referring to me as a
zionist jew pig
and things that are even worse that i
won't say because of our radio
affiliates
so that they don't have to bleep things
um and people saying uh
everything from you are not talking
about it because you're
scared you'll be exposed as the zionist
pig that you are
or it's financial reasons or whatever so
i'm under no illusion that those people
will be satisfied with this segment
unless i unilaterally put the sole blame
for a 70-year conflict at the hands
of genocidal evil israel and anyone who
knows me knows
i would never give such childish black
and white takes on any issue and so
those people who have been emailing me
saying
i deserve to lose my show because i
haven't yet talked about it
i'm sure we'll shift to saying i should
lose my show because of what i say today
this segment is not for them clearly um
there
there were some really wacky things
being emailed to me maybe on other
platforms as well i've really only
looked at emails but maybe things are
crazy on the discord or on reddit i
don't know
uh people saying well clearly i'm not
saying anything because i'm afraid of
the blowback from
from taking a position my audience won't
like that's never stopped me before on
the show
what i have said before is if there's an
issue that's unnecessarily inflammatory
that most of my audience seems not to
care about i would consider skipping it
but i've done dozens of segments on the
israeli-palestinian conflict then i got
emails saying david
you know you should really have the the
uh courage
to do what this other jewish person did
and that other jewish person they were
able to put aside their jewish bias
and take the correct view on this which
is israel is the only problem and israel
in some cases even should not exist as
some people emailed me
david why does your judaism blind you
you can't be a fair arbiter here because
you're jewish
this is the same argument that
right-wingers made during the fight for
gay rights saying
of course gay people want gay marriage
they're biased you can't listen to them
they can't get past their personal
connection to the issue
and it borders on anti-semitic because
it plays on the trope of a dual loyalty
that american jews
have a conflicting loyalty to israel
most jews of course have never been to
israel i've been there once six years
ago i don't live there
you won't be able to engage with me on
things like can't you put aside your
judaism and take the correct position
that's that's an identity politics
rabbit hole it's trash and i don't
engage in that
so i want to focus on what's been taking
place now one last thing
and again i hate that i even have to do
this but you should see what i stepped
into
in my inbox when i when i got in this
morning i also got emails saying david
you're motivated
uh by money so you want to avoid losing
money
if you give an unpopular take and so
that's why you're hiding your view
on the subject and some people writing
and saying you know david you used to
cover the israeli-palestinian conflict
because you had a smaller audience and
you made less money
now there's too much money at stake i'm
going to ignore for a second
again the anti-semitic trope of jews and
money
to say that over time as the show has
been more and more more successful
financial considerations are less and
less
a part of anything i do at this point i
never
chose stories based on money i chose
stories based on do i feel like talking
about it
do i feel like i have something to add
is this something my audience would be
interested in
that's it it's just my show and i pick
the stories every day
financial incentives never dictated
story choice
they especially don't right now and by
the way
if lots of people are interested in the
topic then doing the story would bring
money no matter what i say
hate watching is still watching it still
makes just as much money
so it's not only an incorrect take it's
wrong on the facts as well
all of that now out of the way all of
the reasons
why i've not been not doing a story now
out of the way
let's talk about what's going on and if
you want to engage with me on this
engage
with what i'm actually saying not
anything else that you're bringing in
okay there are arguably two catalysts to
this flare-up and
both have israel to blame both have
israel to blame
both have israel to blame can i find
ways
to maybe say the catalysts are more to
side
i could but they feel disingenuous to me
the narrow catalyst for this
flare-up is israel the first is that a
squad of israeli police officers
entered the al-aqsa mosque in jerusalem
this is a very volatile place
i was there a few years ago non-muslims
are only allowed at al-aqsa
during certain time periods then i don't
know what's going on now
i was lucky to be there at just the
right time we were allowed in the
al-aqsa mosque is
uh controlled by the jordanian authority
within the old city of jerusalem one of
the most interesting places i've ever
been the old city
in general and al-aqsa itself
fascinating historical places
a squad of israeli police officers
entered the aksa mosque
in jerusalem brushed the
palestinian jordanian attendants aside
went across the courtyard and cut the
cables to
loudspeakers that were broadcasting
prayers
during ramadan disastrous idea now why
did they do it
the explanation is the israeli president
not prime minister the israeli president
was delivering a speech at the western
wall
on israeli memorial day you had ramadan
prayers conflicting with a memorial day
speech
so the speakers were cut it's a terrible
idea now you can argue
and unfortunately this is how
intractable this conflict is
where many of us would say oh come on
just you know give this speech somewhere
else or turn down the music or whatever
the turn now the prayers or whatever
that that's not the way this conflict
works
and if you've been following the 70-plus
year history of it you you would see
why this explodes uh but uh i understand
thinking what how is that
uh what was the first catalyst then
we had the upcoming eviction of six
families from the sheikh
jarrah neighborhood a palestinian
neighborhood in east jerusalem
that led to protests then there was a
police raid
on the al-aqsa mosque on may 7th police
officers with tear gas
stun grenades rubber tipped bullets went
into the moss compound
around 8 pm local time and this set off
hours of clashes
with protesters there were hundreds of
injuries according to medics that were
on site as reported by the new york
times
the police say that the stone throwers
started it worshippers are saying
the israeli police started it and then
things exploded as usual each side has
their own view on who the
real wrongdoers are and who is merely
reacting to the other side another
intractable uh bedrock
of every single one of these flare-ups
and there's plenty to go around
dozens and dozens of hamas rockets
coming over from gaza
even reaching tel aviv israel doing
bombings as is always the case
israel's actions leading to more death
now let me say one thing about this
whole
disproportionate response thing that
often is is mentioned
yes israel's response is
disproportionate that's absolutely true
israel is far better armed than the
hamas terrorists in gaza that's
absolutely true
and whenever this happens there tend to
be more deaths
as a result of israeli action that's
absolutely true and that's
horrible i think that we should also be
honest with ourselves
that some of the people who say well if
six palestinians die
and one israeli dies it's a
disproportionate response
i don't think they would be pleased if
the numbers were the same i mean
would we really be seeing a different
reaction from people
if uh 12 palestinians and 12 israelis
died would then would that no longer be
a factor
i don't think so so of course the the
responses disproportionate
disproportionate responses
are a common thing in many conflicts
ethnic political military etc it doesn't
mean it's good
but to focus on that when obviously the
side that's better
armed is likely to do more damage i
don't think it helps us
understand what's going on any better
now then israel did another completely
harebrained thing blowing up a building
in which the associated press was
working in gaza
saying there were hamas there now
maybe there were hamas maybe they
weren't israeli authorities did call and
say
get out because we're going to hit this
building whatever
is the case hamas is in all sorts of
different places
and it just seems idiotic to me to
target this building
because it does exactly what israel's
opponents want to say
israel does which is suppress criticism
and news of what's happening in gaza and
in some
literal sense that's exactly what
happens when you blow up a building out
of which the ap is working so disastrous
idea absolutely condemnable
so let's go through these things first
and i'll tell you where i stand and pay
close attention
because again i'm not going to engage in
responses that mischaracterize what i
say
i am and have been against evictions and
settlements
period for the 25 years i've been
following this conflict
there's no there's no mitigator i
just i'm against it i condemn it uh this
current israeli government
makes me sick and has for a long time
and settlements are a big part of that
one thing that is important and that
tons of people are missing
are that much like the palestinian
people
are different from hamas and the
palestinian authority
and the ultra radical palestinians the
israeli people israel as a country and
the current administration are three
different things
when during the iraq war years some
europeans wrongly
saw all americans as war mongers who
wanted to go to iraq
we all understood why that didn't make
sense we know the difference intuitively
between the trump administration the
united states as a country
and americans as individuals and yet
more than half the emails i received
about this
don't seem to understand or make that
distinction between the netanyahu
administration israel as a country and
the israeli people
uh using the three terms interchangeably
and
that's just a fundamental
misunderstanding of what's going on how
can we even have a remotely sensible
conversation about this conflict
if you interchangeably assign blame or
characterize three separate entities
the current administration israel as a
country and the israeli people as one
one in the same
the evictions from east jerusalem are at
the heart of this and i'm 100
against that they are illegal by
international law period
settlers are radical extremists i share
nothing with them
i am diametrically opposed settlers are
a tiny fraction
of israeli jews who are just a portion
of world jews
unless someone says i'm for the
settlements
i assume that uh they are not because
this is such a radical uh
and relatively fringe group settlers are
in a sense massive provocateurs
shameless ones at that and sadly right
now
the netanyahu government is benefiting
from the settlers and so they are
allowing this to happen
second i am 100 against the netanyahu
government which i believe
is allowing this to happen for the
benefit of benjamin netanyahu
the depraved and disgusting right-wing
prime minister
netanyahu knows his days are numbered he
was unable to form a government so he is
allowing this to happen now
because this is how he operates look at
the chaos you need me he pulled this
before an election
some years ago now this is when maybe
some people
want me to start saying who is to blame
and to what degree david
please say this conflict is 99 israel or
say it's all hamas or you are a
hamas sympathizer nothing is that simple
what i will tell you is what i see is
the most likely path to peace for the
long term
and it requires both netanyahu and likud
not to be in power on the israeli side
and somehow
for hamas to be removed from power in
gaza
but not replaced by hezbollah which is
essentially as bad but better armed
so here's my perspective if you said
what is the most likely path to peace
and this is why i didn't have much to
say initially in this
because fundamentally the path to peace
has not changed in my view
so starting with the big picture anyone
who thinks that there should be no
palestinian state in the future
is just not a productive participant
here the palestinians
need a state of their own a contiguous
one which i will get to
anyone who thinks there should be no
country of israel
is also not a productive participant and
if you really want to see a situation
where many people would die
it would be an a real attempt uh
but by serious players um to make israel
no longer a country so the palestinian
people deserve a state and to live in
peace
and the israeli people do as well and
right now
neither side is being led by those who
benefit from peace or who want it
until that changes nothing will change
so the first question is who's in charge
in a hypothetical peaceful situation in
israel it's not
netanyahu and it's not likud
okay on the palestinian side hamas must
be replaced by a more secular
palestinian authority immediately
hezbollah replacing hamas won't get us
to serious peace possibilities
does mahmoud abbas have a role to play
there currently overseeing the west bank
maybe i'm open to that it doesn't seem
hamas is open to that
when you look at how long a boss has
been around i think you can also
increasingly make the case that abbas is
not a likely arbiter
to a longer-term piece a boss has also
given you know lie riddled speeches at
the u.n
so has benjamin netanyahu to the extent
that a boss
might be a productive partner i'm open
to it being a mahmud abbas
coalition government west bank and gaza
but i don't know how feasible that
really is
um in all likelihood you are going to
need to have
the law of return for jews to israel
means maintained
and a law of return established for the
future palestinian state now
the entire point of israel is since jews
uh
were kicked out and discriminated of so
many parts of the world for so long
that's a place jews know they can go
even if hungary turns extremely
right-wing anti-semitic or
anti-semitic or whatever the case may be
um there also is going to have to be
i believe some ability
for palestinians to return to israel
something's going to have to be conceded
mathematically
and this is something yasser arafat
talked about in the 90s
it's not going to be 5 million
palestinians it's just not going to
happen
so we need a combination of some
reasonable
palestinian return to what will be the
state of israel
certainly the palestinian state will be
able to decide
who is allowed to go there as well
anyone who wants to move back to gaza or
the west bank would be free to do so
if the palestinian authority wants to
allow it now ahud barak in the past
proposed a symbolic number of
palestinian return to israel
and significant financial reparations
that's something that could be looked at
uh i but but that's more details once we
get
past sort of the big uh uh questions
in terms of the land what are the
borders right
um i believe the most likely uh
path to peace will come with something
that is more or less the clinton
proposed borders
uh or symbol which is similar to a lot
of the recent ideas not the trump ideas
forget trump trump anything trump said
is in the trash
the palestinian territory would include
the west bank gaza and east jerusalem
yes east jerusalem there are some
problems
with exactly what the limits of east
jerusalem would be because they are
disputed but
let's imagine if we got to this point
they could be agreed upon
east jerusalem would become the capital
of the palestinian state
i think that has to be conceded and the
caveat would be
the jewish quarter of east jerusalem
should remain under israeli sovereignty
we could do just a whole show on this
but if you look at the desecration
of the jewish quarter when it was not
under israeli control from i believe 49
to 67
you can read more about that i think
that is a caveat
on settlements i mean just all
settlements have to stop immediately
israel has to agree in principle to
remove
settlements that can be removed
and to offer meaningful land swaps for
those that cannot now as a practical
reality and i also go back to what
arafat said about this
not all the settlements at this point
can be realistically removed i hate that
that's disgusting uh but if you say
david
you're the pragmatist negotiator morally
i have no problem with removing every
settlement and i know the talking point
is well these are people's homes yes
they're people's homes that were built
in violation of international law
and they never should have been built
yasser arafat had the idea
that keeping the larger settlements in
exchange for
meaningful land swaps would be okay
that's probably something that would
would have to be negotiated
and then um certainly uh on the other
hand you know all settlements have to
stop
um i believe the blockade has to be
lifted to gaza
you do have to have some way of
preventing
um uh weapon materials from being
brought in it has to be negotiated but
the blockade as a sign of good faith at
least initially has to be lifted of
course
palestinians uh have to immediately all
palestinian groups
have to stop all rockets immediately uh
stop the tunnel building
uh so on and so forth hamas and other
groups have to demilitarize gaza as part
of a peace agreement
um we saw in the two-year period after
the withdrawal of israel from gaza but
before the blockade was put in place
you know thousands of rockets so there
has to be a demilitarization but the
gaza blockade has to be removed and as
long as the demilitarization
and no rockets are held to the deal the
the blockade has to be removed
how do you hold people to that i don't
know that has to be figured out
and then lastly the eventual peace
agreement has to include
that all claims are being renounced and
it is the end of the conflict period
because the problem you run into
is you have some sort of an agreement in
principle
but not all claims are renounced and
then when the agreement is violated
everybody goes back to pretending like
this was never
identified as the end of the conflict if
there's going to be a serious deal
once the right players come to the table
and as i already mentioned who those are
is complicated uh it has to be
determined
that that is the end of the conflict and
in the future
that allows any violator of the
agreement either on the israeli or the
palestinian side
to be held to account some non-binding
thing is not going to get us what we
need
if you want to react address these
specific points
all insults anti-semitic responses
blanket replies like what i had over the
weekend in my email zionist pig
it's all going to be ignored the winners
here
are netanyahu and hamas chaos
from which netanyahu can say you need me
to protect you
that's a gift hamas justified in its
brutal grip on the gazan people
because look at what israel is doing to
us we're the only ones who can respond
with the rockets
the palestinian people lose here the
israeli people lose
bibi wins and hamas wins i look forward
to hearing your thoughts
what if you could read 10 books in just
one sitting that's exactly what one of
my favorite apps lets you do it's called
blinkist and what they do is take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
they condense them down into text or
audio that you can consume in 15 minutes
blinkist makes sure that you're getting
all of the
important core insights from each book
so it's perfect for exploring a book you
otherwise wouldn't have time for
if there's a full book you're thinking
about buying you can use blinkist to get
a sample
first just think how much you can enrich
yourself
by being able to soak up an entire
non-fiction book
in just 15 minutes i recently read a
brief history of time of course by the
great stephen hawking this is a book
that i have been aware of for so long
and
other things got in the way and it was
fantastic to check it out on blinkist
blinkist has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different non-fiction categories and a
subscription is only about
8 bucks a month and you get the entire
library
but you can try it totally free and get
25
off a subscription when you go to
blinkist.com
david pakman i've put the link right
underneath this video
remember that the david pakman show is
made possible
mostly by members who sign up at
joinpackman.com
grab yourself a membership uh this you
just have to see
for more than a year now the right has
been saying open everything
stop masks open schools open restaurants
to full capacity
look at all these left-wing doomers
saying close everything forever
just open it up now of course over time
if we started to vaccinate people we've
started to open things but joe biden was
going too slowly for them or so they
said
he wasn't doing enough biden keeps
wearing his mask he's going too slowly
vaccinated people don't need
masks so last week the cdc comes out and
says hey
we have more information about how
effective these vaccines are
and they are so effective that
vaccinated people don't really need
masks outdoors indoors
but still pay attention to state rules
and pay attention to the businesses
the rules of businesses that you're in
great fox news and right wingers are
thrilled right
wrong check out all the new complaints
that these bad faith actors came up with
first
fox news runs a very suspicious story
pointing out that cdc chief moves from
impending doom
to no masks for the vaccinated in 45
days
on march 29th dr rochelle wallensky
warned the nation of
dire days ahead and yet suddenly
no more masks for vaccinated people
in many situations pending state
guidelines
that's suspicious even though she did
what the trumpists have been asking for
for a year even before it was safe to do
it totally bad faith totally pathetic
here's another one after this
announcement about masks from the cdc
joe biden also made a statement updating
people on the new cdc guidance for masks
fox news interviews
republican senator shelly moore capito
from west virginia
and the story is well why didn't joe
biden thank donald trump
why didn't joe biden thank operation
warp speed why didn't joe biden thank
alex azar can you imagine i know it's
laughable
but check this out were you struck by
the fact that the president did
he does not make a single mention of
operation warp speed
whether it's redfield or azar or jarrar
or president trump
none of that came yesterday how come
well i mean
i i'm always one that wants to give
credit where credit is is warranted and
certainly
operation warp speed president trump put
all of this into motion
and and president biden has followed
through on it so the news
isn't look at the progress what great
news joe biden and the cdc liberating
people
the story is biden said it but he didn't
thank trump
and he didn't thank robert redfield or
alex azar
or operation warp speed and yet if we're
giving credit for putting things in
motion
where are these very people about the
january 6th riots
that donald trump put in motion they're
very quiet
there it really takes gumption
to find something bad about an
announcement
that they wanted all along that for the
first time in over a year
if you're vaccinated if you follow the
cdc guidelines
you don't have to wear masks if joe
biden built a thousand miles of wall on
the southern border fox news would be
saying can we afford this
these immigrants are escaping drug
cartels after all
this is too expensive if joe biden said
guns for everyone no background checks
you got it republicans just have at it
newsmax would say what if a kid hurt
themselves
why doesn't joe biden care about kids
they deserve
none of our consideration as serious
participants in any discussion
because they aren't serious participants
in any discussion
there is a stunning new report out of
politico
that officials in palm beach florida are
actively contingency planning
for a possible indictment of former
president donald trump
by manhattan district attorney psy vance
jr
which could happen while donald trump is
at his florida club
mar-a-lago that this is even something
being
gamed out by palm beach officials is
stunning
the sources here are two high-ranking
county officials from palm beach
involved in these planning sessions
the real legal question is that of
extradition from florida to new york
in the event of a new york indictment of
trump now what's ironic or tragic or
i don't know what to call it is that
because of an obscure florida statute
about interstate
extradition it would basically come down
to the florida governor
who currently is the pro-trump
republican governor ron desantis
who could ultimately decide to intervene
and do an investigation of his own
to determine whether the indicted person
should be extradited to another state
joe abruzzo clerk of the circuit court
of palm beach county says quote
the statute leaves room for
interpretation that the governor has the
power to order a review
and potentially not comply with the
extradition notice
now on the other hand trump is currently
moving from mar-a-lago in florida to his
bedminster new jersey estate for the
summer
if a new york city indictment came down
with trump in jersey
it's a different ballgame there's also a
statute there allowing the governor to
intervene
but the governor in new jersey is
democrat phil murphy
not a trump sycophant brown-noser would
likely just not get involved at all
and if trump were in new jersey at the
time of the indictment trump likely
would be extradited to new york so
there's multiple layers here to consider
first of all imagine a former president
getting indicted period would be one of
the biggest
news stories in american political
history period second
imagine if former president trump is
indicted and he's in florida
and florida governor ron desantis
refuses to extradite trump
consider what that would mean in terms
of the legal insanity of a governor
protecting a former president from
extradition
on an indictment and that trump would
essentially become a fugitive
in his own country at least to his
native new york
and likely wouldn't be able to travel to
new york on the risk of arrest
now i think that while desantis would
plot
plausibly intervene there are plenty of
republican officials who love the idea
of trump
and an indictment as a way to finally
get trump out of the way
and try to commandeer trump's very
constituents for themselves
these would be the republicans who
publicly still stand by trump
but probably privately think he's an
idiot and bad for the republican party
could ron desantis even try to intervene
but in exchange for something imagine
desantis going to trump and saying
i'll intervene to stop the extradition
but then you owe me
and what i want is for you not to run in
2024
and to endorse me for president in 2024.
i don't know but trump being stuck in
florida without being able to leave
is already pretty rich having to endorse
the guy that saves him would be a just
delightful possibility now do i think
any of this will happen
very unlikely i know we've all thought
about that perp walk
that potential moment where donald trump
is handcuffed and walked in front of the
cameras but that is so
far from a real possibility even if
trump were indicted he wouldn't be
perp-walked it would all be very quiet
and quite frankly
i think it's all very far-fetched but
the fact
that it's potentially real enough that
officials around the country
are thinking about if trump is indicted
how do we handle it
that's already historic and it is
absolutely stunning that it's the
discussion
monday memorial day we are doing a
one-day membership special
okay this is what we call a single day
membership
bomb if you want to get in on a
membership
including all of the great benefits as
well as the world's famous award-winning
bonus show
monday memorial day is a beautiful day
to do it just get on my newsletter go to
davidpakman.com
upper right of the website you type in
your email address you get on my
newsletter
monday memorial day you'll get an email
telling you exactly
how to take advantage of this special
quick break back after this
the number one funding source for the
david pakman show
has been and continues to be membership
and membership is not just a feel-good
thing you get access to the world famous
bonus show
every single day just for members as
well as commercial free
audio and video feeds of the show
day in and day out you can sign up for
membership
very very quickly at joinpackman.com
that's
join pakman.com
if the normal prices strike you as high
by
all means use the coupon code better21
all one word all lowercase become a
member today
one of the things i've been saying
during this pseudo scandal involving
republican congresswoman liz cheney is
that we should not forget who liz cheney
is
liz cheney is nothing more than a
republican with whom i disagree on
basically every relevant policy question
and she happens to correctly believe
that joe biden won the election and it
shouldn't be a controversial belief
that is it and it's been disappointing
to see even some on the supposed left
talk about we should stand with liz
cheney
stand with her for what republicans want
a stripper of her leadership role as
they did let let them figure it out
i don't care to defend liz cheney one
way or the other sure it's funny it's
curious to see the incredible double
standard
where the right claims to oppose
so-called cancellation
and yet they canceled liz cheney's
leadership position for something
that should be uncontroversial which is
trump trump really lost the election
that's it but i have no interest in
defending liz cheney or standing with
liz cheney and case in point
she was interviewed by fox news's bret
bayer late last week and on one issue
the 2020 election results she did a
really great thing
she told fox news host brett bayer your
network has to tell the truth
about this issue bret bear didn't like
it lots of people did
that a republican went on fox news and
said you need to tell the truth about
the election let's take a look
i continue to say it though but right i
continue to say i believe it's in
principle
but it's it's because it's people of
wyoming who are electing a
congressperson
to fight for them and to fight against
the biden agenda why wouldn't they say
is this the person that's going to get
it done that's what your colleagues are
at
i'm going to answer the question we all
have an obligation and i would say
fox news especially especially fox news
has a particular obligation to make sure
people know the election wasn't stolen
fox news brad i'm going to answer your
question fox news needs to make sure
that the americans mentioning fox news
they need to make sure that the american
people brett
you're doing the interview i'm answering
the questions congresswoman we need to
make sure
that the american people recognize and
understand
that the election wasn't stolen that we
shouldn't perpetuate the big lie
and that there's real danger you know
i've worked in countries around the
world
okay so it's great right i mean i agree
that's great seeing a republican do that
on fox news that's great stuff
but then and this is the bigger point
bret bayer asks
liz cheney did you vote for joe biden
she's so anti-trump did you vote for joe
biden
and she says not only did she not vote
for joe biden against trump
she would never vote for any democrat
period doesn't matter who it is
take a look and we are going to abide by
the rule of law do
you believe that america is better off
with president biden than president
trump
i believe that president trump's
policies which i supported 93 percent of
the time
were much better for america now that
isn't the issue though
the issue is whether or not we abide by
the rule of law
what i did not whether and i would not
and i would not vote for a democrat
ever do not forget who liz cheney is
her depraved immoral party of which
she's a proud member
did her wrong okay they can figure it
out we're not standing with her or them
she may be anti the former guy
anti-trump
but she's still a right winger and a
radical one is that
as left as i am i would never make a
proactive preemptive blanket statement
like i would never vote for a republican
if you give me a specific race and the
republican is better
than the democratic option then i'd vote
for the republican it's that simple the
fact that she's making such a statement
with no caveats about
the quality of the republican and the
quality of the democrat
really shows us what we should have
already known which is liz cheney is no
different
than the trump mccarthy wing of the
party
with some slightly different beliefs but
remember she voted with trump what was
it 92 percent of the time
something like that she's burning a
bridge that's already on fire and we
shouldn't see it as a particularly brave
move or anything like it i don't take
sides in the trumpian civil war
it's bad for them let the war rage i
have no interest in defending anybody on
either side of it mitt romney anti-trump
republican
didn't vote for trump marched with black
lives matter okay
he was asked okay mr mr romney sir now
that biden's president what next
and he said his priority is preventing
tax increases and preventing socialism
these are not our friends and it's
important not to be tricked into
thinking they are
liz cheney has been silent on the voter
suppression uh bills that have been uh
spreading nationally she's doing nothing
to speak out against it
she just doesn't believe that trump won
she doesn't believe that lie it's not
heroic
and this is why liz cheney shouldn't be
lionized
just for being one republican willing to
tell
one simple truth at the end of the day
she doesn't
really want anything to change and you
heard it from her she would never vote
for any democrat period
so we've covered one side of the liz
cheney fiasco
which is republicans have stripped
republican congresswoman liz chaney from
her leadership role because she admits
joe biden won the election
and trump is lying when he says that he
won and he should stop
that's the one side now on the other
side
of that is that liz cheney was replaced
by someone and that someone is
republican congresswoman elise stefanik
who now becomes republican conference
chair after liz cheney's removal
the pro-trump right wing is going
absolutely crazy about elise stefanik
they just love her
and sadly elise stefanik is sort of a
better spoken marjorie taylor green or
lauren bober she's just as nutty don't
be confused
she just knows how to better present her
ideas
to appear less outrageous and case in
point
she gets herself a congratulatory pat on
the back interview
uh on fox news this weekend conducted by
none other than trump suck up maria
bartoromo and right away
it goes to the big lie about the
election being stolen and again
stefanik doesn't indicate that her
opinion is any different
than marjorie taylor-green's on this
issue she just knows how to better frame
her answer
to be about her constituents and
election integrity
but she has no problem accepting maria
bartoromo's framing of the question so
check it out and understand that maria's
question is
do you think there will be a fair
election in 2022 which would allow you
to investigate the 2020 election
which was of course stolen it's a
ridiculous question and here's how elise
stefanik answers it
are you expecting a uh a free and fair
election to enable you to do that next
year
well that's one of the really important
issues maria when i go home to my
district and as i talk to my colleagues
this is the case across the country
voters want to make sure that they have
faith in our election system which is
why election integrity and election
security
is a top priority for the american
people and it should matter to you
whether you're republican democrat or
independent this is why you're seeing
state legislatures
like florida like arizona taking action
to address
and strengthen their election systems
this is why she's so slippery
that's right americans care about secure
election systems and we have them
the 2020 election was not close it was
one of the most secure that we've had
and as always with some anecdotal
instances of irregularities
not nearly a fraction of what you'd need
to change the results in any one state
it doesn't matter though because that's
not what elise stefanik will tell you
she'll tell you since it matters to my
constituents it was also irregular
we need major action what they mean by
this
is we didn't suppress enough of the vote
in 2020. if you look at her comments
outside of this interview since her
election since the election
you get a sense for her point of view
she's promoted conspiracy theories about
a stolen
election hours after the invasion of the
capital on january 6th
she voted against accepting
pennsylvania's electoral votes
on january 12th harvard university
announced they are removing stefanik
from its institute of politics
because of her role in promoting these
false claims
but she's better at talking about it to
sound marginally less off the wall
than some of her colleagues and that
makes her dangerous here's a little bit
more and then it sort of comes mask off
we need voter identification we need
chain of custody when it comes to the
absentee mail-in ballots
signature verifications and what the
democrats have put forward
is a federal takeover to put them into
power
forever the for the politicians act hr1
which would be taxpayer-funded campaigns
completely off the rails a sensible
reform
sensible reforms are radical far left
it's absolutely a crazy authoritarian
clampdown on voting
which they want republicans are talking
about election integrity but that's not
really what they want here she's
horrifying and then just for a little
more flavor
the interview ends with elise stefanik
talking about how great donald trump is
it's almost like a rite of passage on
maria bartoromo's show
yeah real quick congressman before you
go president trump supported you to get
the third highest rank
uh in the gop how important is he to the
party right now
he's critical to the party he is the
leader of the republican party
voters determine the leader of the
republican party and they continue to
look
to president trump for his vision and
he's going to be important part of us
winning back the house in 2022.
all right we will leave it there
congrats again congresswoman we hope
you'll come back we will be watching the
developments thank you so much
so there it is pledging full and total
loyalty to donald trump it's all his for
the taking
and as far as elise stefanik is
concerned trump gets to pick republican
winners in 2022
and trump gets to run in 2024 if he so
wants
and she will support him blindly
and to the ends of the earth this is the
republican party right now
cheney out that's what liz cheney was
replaced by
and if this tells us anything about the
next couple of years
it's that it doesn't seem the republican
party is going to be freeing itself
from the grip of trump send me your
thoughts if you disagree you can find us
on instagram
at david pakman show find me on
instagram
david.pakman the david pakman show is
audience supported media and you can
contribute
any amount you want on patreon as little
as one dollar per month
plus you can get the daily bonus show
world famous at this point
and the daily commercial free tv show
by making those pledges at patreon.com
slash david pakman show this is audience
supported media we depend on the support
of our viewers and listeners
whether you listen to the podcast watch
on youtube or watch us on tv
or even listen on the radio patreon.com
david pakman show an outrageous and
shocking video of now congresswoman
marjorie taylor greene
showing up at the house of
representatives in february of 2019
going to alexandria ocasio-cortez's
office
and shouting outrageous three things
through the mail slot
in the door has been found and published
the video has since been deleted and it
really starts to tell a bigger story
about the obsessive almost stalker-like
harassment
of aoc by marjorie taylor greene
and the reason that this is again in the
news is that marjorie taylor green
confronted alexandria ocasio-cortez
again outside the house chamber last
week and it has people talking about is
this criminal is this
rising to the point of being stalking in
some sense and all sorts of other
questions
we now have to add to this a new video
which shows a longer pattern of this
ridiculous behavior
check out the first part of the video
you want to talk to crazy ocasio you
come to this little thing and you open
it up and you whisper
into it this is confession
this is this is ocasia confession right
alexandria ocasio-cortez i'm an american
citizen
i pay your salary through the taxes that
you collect from me through the irs
because i'm a tax paying citizen of the
united states
i'm a woman i'm a female business owner
so that you really understand the optics
if you're just listening on the radio or
to the audio podcast
in the video marjorie taylor green is
bent over at the waist
speaking through the mail slot on aoc's
door
i like i'm a woman and i'm a female this
woman is really disgusting i mean just a
vile vile person
let's keep watching and i'm proud to be
an american woman
and i do not support your socialist
policies and i do not support your
murderous abortion policies
as a mother of three children i am
appalled at new york's law for abortion
and it needs to end and it needs to stop
now you're bringing god's judgment on
our country
and i'm against it as well as my friends
now i have to break in for a moment
not that any of this makes sense but how
is new york state abortion policy
related to aoc
aoc lived in new york uh
and worked in jobs that had nothing to
do with policy and then
she was elected a member of congress
representing new york and washington dc
federally
the federal government doesn't decide
state law on abortion in new york
you would think marjorie taylor green
might know that since she's about states
rights
let's continue so you need to stop being
a baby and stop
locking your door and come out and face
the american citizens that you serve
if you want to be a big girl you need to
get rid of your diaper
and come out and be able to talk to the
american citizens putting aside
that marjorie taylor green is a
congresswoman
this kind of behavior you know take off
your diaper
this kind of behavior is humiliating and
embarrassing for any adult to be seen
doing
but it's not just a random person it
happens to be someone who's now a member
of congress herself marjorie taylor
green now there
there is another aspect to this um
friday aoc told reporters that green is
quote
deeply unwell and clearly needs help
and her kind of fixation has lasted for
several years now
this is something that remains difficult
because on the one hand
you see that video of marjorie taylor
green and you see her speeches and her
behavior and the way she speaks and
looks at people it's sort of obvious
that she's unwell there does
seem to be a mental illness component
here
but in addition to that she's a radical
republican who doesn't
deserve to be in congress because of her
beliefs mental health is a major issue
which we don't stigmatize on this
program and marjorie taylor green
does seem to need help if a doctor
determines so
medication as well but we can't pretend
this
is only mental illness and that's why
every time we bring this up and i'm sort
of glad aoc did because it allows us the
opportunity to talk about it
when we talk about oh this person is
saying crazy things politically
they're mentally ill it's not that
simple marjorie taylor green is
different
than mitt romney mitt romney has views
that i disagree with but i've never seen
an indication
that mitt romney seems to be unwell in
the way that marjorie taylor green is
unwell
but that doesn't excuse the disgusting
political beliefs either
we can't pretend it's only mental
illness it's also a radicalized
indoctrinated individual
who's harassing a member of congress
regularly if an
employee at most companies did this to
another employee
they would be fired period that's it and
the republican party is so sick the
voters that is
that marjorie taylor green is
fundraising off of these confrontations
so
absolutely off the rails and unclear if
there will be any consequences to that
we also learned that marjorie taylor
green is involved in a
a tax fraud let's talk about that next
i love this story because it combines
radical right wing arrogance with real
estate and tax law which are all things
that i enjoy
we have now learned that ridiculous
radical right robot
congresswoman marjorie taylor green
filed homestead exemptions or
homestead declarations as they are
sometimes called
on two homes which is against the law
this is as we like to say a fraud she
made a fraud
let's first talk about homestead
exemptions a homestead exemption
is a legal declaration that lets you say
this home i own
this is my primary residence it is where
i am
sheltered and in exchange for such a
declaration
the value of your home is protected from
property tax claims from creditors from
forced sales and a number of other
circumstances
in normal cases the way debt works in
the u.s
is that you can have situations where
you could be forced to sell an asset to
pay off a creditor or a debt
that you owe a homestead exemption or
declaration lets you say
this property is my home this is my
residence this is where i live
it's not a second home it's not an
investment property and so
by declaring it a homestead you can't be
forced to sell that home to pay your
debts they can't leave you homeless to
pay your debts
this is separate from for foreclosure
but
it's a very particular type of
declaration in some states
only some portion of the home's value is
protected and that amount can vary
texas has no dollar value limit some
states do and additionally many states
give you a tax break because you do not
have to pay property taxes on some
portion of your home's value so
if a certain state exempts a hundred
thousand dollars of value with a
homestead declaration
if the house is worth 500k but 100k is
exempt you
pay property taxes as if the house were
worth only 400 000.
okay but here's the the rule you can
only do it on one property
channel two action news in atlanta did
an investigation and found
that marjorie taylor green and her
husband have two
active homestead exemptions which is
against the law in georgia the greens
are getting a tax break on
two homes in two different counties
channel two news
pulled the greens homestead exemption
application in fulton county
and in floyd county uh oh in the floyd
county application
marjorie taylor green's husband left
blank the line which says
do you have an exemption on another
property that is a lie
biomission i recall talking to my real
estate attorney about this
a couple of years back and i asked when
we were talking about
different transactions i've been
involved in and the homestead
declaration i asked how often do people
get caught
for this he said you know i know of many
people that do this
and they do get away with it marjorie
taylor green appears to have gotten
caught
fulton county tax officials confirm that
green
never stopped getting the tax break on
the fulton property
but declared it on the floyd county
property now there are at least in
theory consequences for doing this this
is defrauding the state to be clear
the penalty for filing a false homestead
exemption according to georgia code is
twice your tax bill
for the greens that would be about
twelve thousand dollars there were two
statements put out by green's office
the first statement was this is merely a
pathetic smear
that was statement number one this
escalated
and then the second statement was
calling this fake
news and saying this was just an error
by fulton county
the uh the greens are claiming they
requested
the homestead exemption be cancelled for
the fulton county
but maybe because of covid i don't know
they never did it but now they've got it
all fixed up so she's going with that
she's going with we did everything right
but something something covered and it
prevented it from happening that doesn't
explain
why they didn't answer the question do
you have an active homestead exemption
on another property right now the answer
was yes
they left that blank it seems like a
clear line by omission
maybe it was lost in the mail which was
destroyed by donald trump's crony louis
de joy
but the simplest explanation is that
this is fraud
marjorie taylor green is making up that
she tried canceling it
and that they intentionally lied and
they got caught plain and simple
now the question of whether there will
be consequences
you all know uh how that works uh with
when it comes to people in positions of
power in the united states so
i don't know but i'm certainly not
confident that there will be
any consequences but an apparent fraud
committed by marjorie taylor greene and
her husband the party of rules and law
and order and all of this stuff don't
forget that
we have a voicemail number that number
is 219
to david p here's a caller who says
woke and cancellations are
merely constructs that don't exist
what let's take a listen
yes sir um i'm calling
simply because the terms
woke and cancel don't exist
they are constructs that have been
created by social media
it would be useful if you stopped
promoting them
well first of all i don't really promote
them we do
talk about them on the show in a sense
isn't everything a construct
i mean like i guess a rock isn't a
construct it's a physical
rock but aren't most
political discussions made up of
constructs and things that as societies
we've agreed
i don't know i'm having trouble
following it let's listen to a little
more these
are words that people think they know
what they're talking about
rest assured they do not um
woke what does that mean
that you suddenly become aware of the
fact that there is injustice in america
cancel well you know we have other
terms and phrases for
disavowing those who fail to meet our
criteria
but you know imagining that this is in
some way
associated with a culture is just
bizarre
so i'm hoping we can get you to stop
uh using these words as they have been
presented so i often get voicemails
asking me not to do something that i've
not done
or responding to things i haven't
covered i don't use the term woke in an
unironic way
the only times i've used the term woke
are to point point fun
at its absurd usage by others
so i mean listen in a sense all of these
concepts are constructs we
we always have synonyms we can use
but i don't really know what exactly the
point is of the call
particularly since when i talk about the
left
can't i'm sorry when i talk about the
right has canceled someone
while claiming to be against
cancellations i am sort of using the
term tongue-in-cheek
when i talk about woke-ism
it's often a reaction to the rights kind
of weird use of it but i don't use the
term woke in a real way so maybe the
caller and i are on the same page but at
the same time maybe we're not i don't
really know
we have a fantastic bonus show for you
today joe biden has
cancelled speaking of which donald
trump's planned national garden of
american heroes and it's triggering
people and
we're going to talk about the origins of
it and much more this is a funny story a
bunch of people sent me
harry styles who's a british musician
got an award recently
and he seemed to no longer have a
british accent and i have a bunch of
funny related stories about this uh
and i think it'll be an entertaining
story at minimum
and then we do still have at least in
theory the rescheduled
olympics uh coming um later this year to
japan
80 of the japanese oppose the olympics
being done in japan this summer we're
going to talk about why what's going on
the preparations that are being made
could it be done safely etc etc
um and much more including some of the
upcoming plans for the show
over the next few weeks don't miss
today's bonus show that's just a
suggestion it's not an authoritarian
demand it's just
i think you would enjoy the bonus show
you can get
instant access to it by signing up at
joinpakman.com that also comes with many
other great benefits including
the commercial free version of the daily
audio
and video show the members only
newsletter
invitations to occasional members only
town halls and other events
and the pleasure of knowing your
supporting alternatives
to homogenous corporate media sign
up at joinpackman.com and i will see you
in mere
moments on today's bonus trip
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors blinkist is the
app that helps you become a more
well-rounded person
by letting you read or listen to an
entire nonfiction book in just 15
minutes
you can try it for free and get 25 off a
subscription
by going to blinkist.com david pakman